[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous pensez transports en
commun parisiens écoutez moi je pense
qu'ils sont vraiment très très bien
moi je l'espère y habiter beaucoup à
l'étranger donc je peux comparer et là
je trouve qu'ils sont excellents les
travaux parisienne l'autre elle en pense
quoi
comment votre frère il en pense quoi mon
frère mais il me amidou même avis que
moi
basket
ouais je n'avais pas vu même si aulas
mais gusta certains sports québec et
linde ok lindo parisse latino la salle
par salle à propre votre alors ont-ils
ajouté
chen me faire plaquer par pierrick ont
tapé ses trois voyages tu appelles et
yann le plaqué sur install il était
coralie sur un stade en train de hashtag
porte food en train de manger chaque pan
de foot je suis dégoûté ça me sarah
c'est la fille de tahiti bob à s'acheter
dichato a du coup je vais tenter ma
chance avec arnaud et apéritif comme ça
à pierrick pierrick s'ils regardent
c'est pierrick ça tu leur as to speech
par eric se disent et finissent derrière
toi ça il ya des lignes qui sont moins
encombré que d'autres mais après on est
toujours très serré les gens ne sont pas
agréables sont ils tous ceux ils sont
pas souriant et puis rien qu'ils sont
qui reste plantée au milieu c'est un bon
voilà vol en pense quoi sommes pas à
toulouse
khadjimba à la somme fou des transports
au namm cabrio cela donne deux graves
babou yara aux autres
[Musique]